even sending a big message to the world
from a small town in the south of the
Netherlands three sisters between the
ages of 12 and 14 produced this video
and posted it to nearly 300,000
followers as part of the black lives
matter campaign it was viewed more than
a million times what's going on with
racial crisis he posted video changes
that 2020 is now the time and we have to
change we don't have to wait any longer
and I think it's very good that people
are now coming to the streets and yeah
one justice having experienced racism
themselves at a young age they urge
other teenagers to learn about the
history of slavery and colonialism the
same message Noah is spreading in
Belgium the fourteen-year-old has
collected nearly 80 thousand signatures
after he initiated a petition to remove
statues of King Leopold the second the
colonialists leader has been accused of
mass murder in the former Belgian colony
of Congo
it is like you put a statue of Hitler in
the middle of Berlin
I think Jewish people would feel very
uncomfortable in Berlin if that would
happen I feel the same here someone who
has murdered so many people does not
deserve to be honored protests also in
the Netherlands against colonial statues
like this one honoring a man accused of
mass murder in the former colony now
Indonesia
researchers say previous generations
grew up to be more focused on their own
lives and successes while young people
now show more solidarity with others I
think young people are fed up they've
been trying to say hey we should be
mindful of our history we should be
mindful of institutional mechanisms of
in an exclusion of institutional racism
and the politicians aren't doing
anything if it were up to these girls in
Amsterdam the first thing politicians
should change is education inspired by
the protest in the United
States they filed a petition to make it
mandatory to teach about racism in Dutch
schools it received so much support that
Parliament has to consider it I think
connecting to other people no matter
what their race is no matter what their
color age is it's just a way to connect
more and you get inspired by owners
pieces yeah if you see like people
protesting or whatever then you want to
do the same thing 2020 is the year of
change that's what all these young
activists would like to believe step
fasten al-jazeera Meyerson in the south
of the Netherlands